[Music]
i'm christopher hine and we're going to
make some more videos for you guys about
khan renwazza so we have a three-part
series here on udeoce
the the the
breakdown of this is a little different
than the first video i made because the
first video i kind of had to explain
what conrad wazza was as we went and now
i'm assuming you've seen that video if
you haven't you should watch the first
video on conor nawaza which is on the
patreon page and you can see it no
problem it's also on youtube you can see
it
but we're going to talk here about the
extension of the udeoce which comes off
of that ikyo and udeose just means the
arm pinning technique or arm controlling
technique so
from that we're going to see what the
takedown's about what the conron for the
takedown is and that's going to be this
video we're also going to then follow up
with a video on
what to do if you cannot get the take
down and then what to do if they can
absolutely overcome you so
we're going to make those three in the
series this first one right now that
you're watching is going to be about the
takedown itself i'm going to get josh
we're going to go to work josh
all right so we're going to talk about
udeo say uh in this portion we're going
to talk about udesay just for the
takedown so what are the adaptations for
the uro
and the takedown
when we're talking about conor nawaz a
lot of the stuff i'm going to show you
you've already learned in aikido forms
you probably just don't recognize it as
answers to upcoming problems once you
understand the whole the syllabus you
can kind of go back and look through it
you can see that
the forum teaches you conrad rather
naturally and
you don't need to go through and learn a
set of chondren but the problem with
that is
you don't is clearly get it as you will
in just studying a set of conjurings so
we're going to talk about the conjuring
for udeo say all right so udeo say just
means arm pin we're going to start right
from this position now you could call
this the ikkyo pin if you want um or
ikiose but
that's only one aspect of all the stuff
that comes from this series all right
now if you happen to have someone in
this position and you want to make the
takedown how does the takedown go
through now you should start with this
with the lead leg being on the outside
and the near leg the leg that's near him
being on the inside and the reason for
that is this makes it most difficult for
him to get a hold of my leg so if i had
his arm here decently if he goes to get
my legs you can see that leg's going to
cost him right he's going to fall down
for that leg if he reaches over for this
other leg it's real hard for him to get
and going to cost him okay however if i
have this leg forward he really easily
can sneak in and grab that leg and
that's going to give me trouble
so before i have this guy in a decent
control position i want to make sure my
near leg is back and my my outside leg
is the far forward leg okay now when i
want to get this guy down what am i
trying to do when he's like he is right
now so that other hand's not touching
that means he's balanced and can balance
on his feet i do not want to step in
until i take that balance away so i need
to in some way get him nudged forward to
do that now the second he touches he
needs three points to be balanced so in
this three point balance i can step
forward because if you were to grab my
leg here he's got no balance and he'll
fall down right so that's the time when
you can safely step in is once this hand
touches until that hand touches you
can't risk stepping in because most
likely he's going to he's going to be
able to get you now understand all this
is coming off of our aikido context i'm
not going to hit that in this video
right now because it'll take too long to
talk about but this came up because of
an inherent imbalance in whatever he was
doing and that's why this came up and
for some reason pinning him was a good
option and there's tons of reasons that
could be there's a situation i need to
control he's armed i need to save other
people all kinds of other stuff talk
about that in other videos but this is
coming off of the aikido context so i
want the outside leg forward near leg is
back until he touches once he touches i
can safely step in now this stepping in
is going to feel better to you because
now i have more weight over the top of
him so it's going to be easier for me to
control this guy now how do i get him
down if i'm lucky when i take my initial
step in
i will bump him off balance and he'll
pretty much get broken down at that
point right so that would be really
fantastic if my initial step is what hit
him so once he he touches there and i
step this leg in my goal is to try and
knock him straight back like that and if
i can break him down there then good and
i'll just work him the rest of the way
down i'll drop the inside leg here and
then i'll go into the pin from here
if after i've got him to touch i step in
and he just adjusts by sticking his hand
out then i'm going to pull him this way
like this okay and he'll shoot his hand
i'll step in and and let me explain
what's going to go on this process all
right and josh is doing a lot of work
here he has to stay in this position so
once his hand touches
that's what's helping him balance over
there he's got nothing balancing over
here so if he's shot his hand out so far
that i didn't break his balance there
there's a possibility to pull him into
this gap here to break him down right
there and that's what i'd like to have
is have that little gap happen but he
can also shoot his hand out here to stop
that from happening but now he's not
balanced over there so i'll drive into
that right so what i'm trying to do when
i when i'm trying to get the take down
from here is move back and forth like
this so he only has one hand to balance
himself and eventually i should be able
to break him down by going back and
forth back and forth back and forth like
that okay now as i'm doing this there's
several things i can do with the arm
okay white right now the way that you're
seeing me do this is a really poor rokyo
so it's against the joint here it's a
bad roku i would prefer to get the ikkyo
if i could right so this ikea what it
does if you watch josh's balance so
watch if i go from here watch me rotate
this elbow i'm already putting him into
a worse position so if i can stay on the
underside of the elbow it's going to be
a lot easier to control him for the
takedown than it is if i can't now he
might not like that so he very well
might straighten that elbow out and keep
me from doing that you're going to
experience this a lot with your ukes
where they're going to try and
straighten their arm out to keep you
from doing that now you have a few
options one of the options is to go
right into the rokio here with your hand
where i press in here and i'm trying to
get this control another option is to
use the straight arm he's giving you to
go into the shoulder so i can go into
the shoulder and i'm driving right into
the shoulder joint with that you can
also readjust this hand to go into a
number of different things one is gokyo
one is nico we can get sankyo so we can
go into a few different things here but
i can use the control at the wrist here
to try and get him to go where i want
so ideally when i'm working this
breakdown here i would like to have this
elbow rolled but if i can't hold that
and he straightens it out i can drive
into the elbow itself i can drive into
the shoulder or i can control this hand
and go into the hand and i can use all
those things to help me start breaking
his balance because while that's going
on i'm going back and forth back and
forth back and forth trying to break his
balance down
let josh stand up here for a sec okay so
that's the objective i've driven into
him and i'm controlling his arm i want
to keep my near leg back until he's
touching once he touches i know that
he's not stable on just the two legs so
that means it's safe to step in when i
step in i want to step in dominantly and
ideally i'll just knock him down when i
do that if i don't do that i'm going to
immediately pull him back to this area
right here where he doesn't have a hand
so what he'll probably try to do is
shoot his hand over there to keep
himself from falling and then i'll drive
over here so basically what's happening
is i'm always pulling where his hand
isn't so if his hand was here i'm gonna
pull him this way when i pull him this
way he'll move his hand over here to
stop himself from falling that way then
i immediately push back here if he moves
his hand back here then i pull back so
back and forth i'm going back and forth
back and forth back and forth to break
him down
if i need a little more encouragement
i'm going to try to use the echo because
eco is going to give me a really nice
advantage as long as i can hold it if i
can't get the eq i could go into the
rokyo with my hand i can go into his
shoulder directly and i can go into a
gokyo or enikyo over here to help get
him down right so those are my main
ideas once i'm in that udeo say position
and i'm trying to get the take down now
if i can't get the takedown what do i do
our next video series we're going to
talk about if you cannot possibly manage
the takedown i'm christopher hine thanks
for watching
[Music]
you